you need to believe in yourself despite
what everybody you love and Trust tells
you Ben and I had a joint bank account
we'd go to New York and if you made
money acting you went into the account
and the account was only to be used if
if you were going to New York for an
audition but I mean we really wrote Good
Will Hunting out of necessity I mean we
just needed a job you don't get anywhere
being you know genuflecting to you know
somebody he's an American actor film
producer and screenwriter he's ranked by
Forbes magazine as one of the most
bankable Hollywood stars and is among
the highest grossing actors of all time
he's received numerous accolades
including one Academy Award from four
nominations he's not Damon and here's my
take on his top ten goals and success
rule number one is my personal favorite
I make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips
when I was younger everybody told me not
to be an actor to this day I say that to
people who come up to me and say I'm
thinking of going into acting what do
you think I say absolutely not it's a
terrible idea don't do it because that's
what everyone said to me and I think if
you're gonna make it in this business
that is so full of rejection and
hardship you need to believe in yourself
despite what everybody you love and
Trust tells you and and it's a very
personal journey and so so that was
really helpful I think you know the
advice to stay away from this career was
really helpful in my own understanding
that it was that important that I pursue
it you know the first job I got was a
real job
besides commercials and things like that
local radio commercials and things that
kind of gave us the money Ben and I had
a joint bank account and we'd go to New
York and if you made money acting you
went into the account and the account
was only to be used if if you were going
to New York for an audition or if we
took $10 out to like play video games
and I got a line in the movie mystic
pizza and the line was mom do you want
my green stuff and literally but it was
a scene that was a big dinner table
scene Julia Roberts we had a good movie
for her and
it was this old dinner table seen and so
it took us three nights to shoot and
down in Mystic Connecticut and I was a
miner so my mother had to come with me
and you know we shot from five to five
every every night and and I just
remember being so in love with the
process of film I just know I was like
this is the greatest it was the best
time I'd ever had in my life and it was
you know I was like this is amazing I
want this to never ever ever stop like I
loved it but I mean we really wrote Good
Will Hunting out of necessity I mean we
just needed a job and we and and you
know as you all know they don't really
give those out here so it was just you
know two guys who were eager and young
and had a lot of energy and a lot of
creative energy and that's a big prep is
always a big problem with LA and New
York was even you know you'd meet these
other actors and they and it's like
you're raring to go and there's nowhere
to put that energy and so you know it
can get put in horrible places they can
get put in you know drugs and all that
you know or you can try to somehow
channel it into something that feels
productive and even if it doesn't
nothing comes of it it's still
productive in the sense that you're
working even if you're getting together
in groups and doing scenes or taking
classes or trying to cobble together a
screenplay the the energy is going
somewhere you have never seemed shackled
map over your career by the fear of
needing to maintain some sort of
particular image you've always been
happy to speak out on issues that you
are concerned about or to do whatever
projects take your fancy how have you
managed to slip those chains I just
never thought that you could micromanage
an image you know I just didn't you know
and and the things I've spoken about
I've just you know are things that I
believe and it doesn't mean that I'm
right it just you know and I'm happy to
to learn and evolve and my thinking and
but um but if I'm saying something it's
because it's what I'm genuinely feeling
and and you know and that that's uh I
don't think I've taken too many hits for
that our high school acting teacher
chair
Becca who had a huge influence on me and
Ben and Kasey five words he said just do
your work kid and he repeated that so
many times to me just do your work kid
and that is kind of what I can always
retreat to you know that's my touchstone
if you know when in doubt just focus on
my work you know if everything on the
movies going wrong all right you know
I'll make sure that my work is tight and
and and go from there and that's a great
place to base from and it's a good
foundation I looked at the odds you know
but like how am I even gonna break into
this business right all the good parts
you know if you as an unknown actor to
get a great role you know every every
other actor has to pass on it right
every other actor has to pass on it and
then it gets opened up to you and
thousands of other people like you right
and you all go and you know there are a
few parts like I was looking at the you
know a big part when I was when I was a
young younger was primal fear remember
that movie with Richard Gere and Edward
Norton got the part everyone passed yeah
I mean so that part became open every
young actor knew it I mean we when I
paid with money I did not have to take
dialect lessons you know hired a dialect
coach because the kid was you know his
alter ego was from Kentucky and he was
from somewhere else and I didn't I had
never been to Kentucky and so you know
every we knew that that was it you know
that was going to launch somebody there
just weren't opportunities you know and
and so courage under fire was one of
those roles that was small it was really
only it was two scenes right I had two
scenes with Denzel and then the rest of
it was I'm the medic and I'm you know
you know Tim Guinea an actor who I love
who's in promised land actually is like
bleeding out on my lap for so for six
weeks we're in El Paso and he's like
moaning and I'm just sitting there and
I'm like I don't think the cameras on us
you know it was it was a really
thankless job for both of us except for
those two scenes that I had with Denzel
so I had two days of work on that movie
and so I went well what do I do you know
it's a it's a it's told in flashback so
let me see how can I change myself what
can I do the guy's supposed to become a
heroin addict okay well so what do I do
to make that seem like it happened and
and the only thing I could come up with
was a to lose as much weight as I could
and then put it back on as fast as I
could to go do the flashback stuff and
so that's what I did
I heard that wasn't good for your health
like your doctor was no terrible you
know it was bad but it was bad because I
didn't you know I asked I asked them for
a nutritionist which was probably $1,500
to $2,500 and and they said no and you
know they I don't think they in their
defense I don't think they really knew
what I was gonna do you know and they'd
probably have requests like this all the
time and they think their vanity request
but it was a serious request and and
they turned it down and so I went to he
had a friend we knew a guy who was also
a he was he was all he was Austrian I
mean funnily enough he was Austrian and
he was a net he was trying to be an
actor but he literally because he was
Austrian he had Arnold's accent and he
was a former bodybuilder so he was
really aiming at a small bullseye you
know because his spot was really taken
by
but he he put me on his program that he
would do for bodybuilding shows but they
would do that program three weeks out
you know they would do this really kind
of reckless thing when they're when
they're just you know and and so those
guys walk on stage and like you could
push it they look strong but you could
you could knock them over they're really
suffering at that point to kind of leech
every bit of everything out so that the
veins and the muscles pop out so so I
did it for like three and a half or four
months which was just too much you know
too much in it and it but at the same
time you know it worked it worked and
you know when I when I got the Rainmaker
a year or so later coppola said that
he'd seen courage under fire and and
that that made a big difference and
funnily enough it was Edward Norton and
I who were going against each other
again for that and and and that courage
under fire pushed me over the edge and
when I met I met Spielberg later and he
looked at me and he said what you know
and I'd put myself on tape for Saving
Private Ryan I never heard anything I
don't think tape ever got to him the
casting director maybe looked at it and
chopped it you know and so I thought
he'd you know seen it and he said well
you know what do I know you from and I
said I put myself on tape for him if he
does know I didn't see any tape because
what movies have you been and I said I
was in a movie called courage under
fought because because you know I turned
to my wife when I saw that movie and
said that's the exact guy I want for
Private Ryan I just wish he wasn't so
skinny
so I feel like I read a interview at the
time that said like you couldn't even
kiss your girlfriend because you could
taste potato chips on her lips the oil
from them ya know I mean it went I
people who have those you know disorders
I got it I totally understood it like if
you want to be it cuz there I just told
myself I can't allow anything there's no
no compromising none like because the
second you open that door you know it's
a slippery slope and I just what I
wanted to look back on it and go I did
absolutely everything I could this
relationship between you and Ben it's a
kind of he bust you and you bust him
back there's a little bit of that a lot
of that it's the nature of two guys
growing up together yeah yeah but
there's also this thing that we're
talking about we just saw in the scene
is that there is that who the two of you
are in terms of to each other oh yeah I
mean we I mean because apart in
Cambridge and all that sure yeah we
could growing up together best friends
all our lives we don't have very you
know I wouldn't say we have moments that
are that kind of dramatic or like listen
man you know but you know I you know lay
down in traffic for the guy I mean you
know he's my best pal you know I mean
you know I'd pretty much do anything for
him so so yeah I mean it's it's a it's a
you know it's a great friendship you
know I can't imagine a better way to
make a movie and do something I'd love
to do that much then then then with Ben
and to have this go the way it did and
and have this happened you know and Tom
Hanks said something to me when we were
doing Saving Private Ryan that always
stuck with me which was I was asking him
about the move a movie did with Jackie
Gleason and I said what was it like to
work with Jackie Gleason and he thought
about it for a second he said you know I
made a decision to not be nervous and I
went what he goes I just I knew everyone
was so nervous around him and I just
said you know what I'm not gonna be
nervous around him I'm just and he and
once he realized I was treating him like
you know a fellow human being we really
had this great working relationship and
it was really good advice you know and
so you try to do that yourself I was
trying to do it with Tom Hanks at the
you know and and yeah and yeah it's a
you don't get anywhere being you know
genuflecting - you know somebody and I
know a lot has been said and written
about the experience of Good Will
Hunting but did you ever have imagined
that it would have such an effect on
people you touched so many lives with
that movie it was amazing no it's really
great looking back I mean it
you've been and been and I made this had
this pact that that we just wanted the
movie that no matter what we wanted to
love it and even if nobody saw it and it
was a great early lesson that you know
because even if it movie hadn't been
successful we still would have loved it
and and it would have meant as much as
much to us so I've you know and you know
not to be a horrible name dropper but
but Clint Eastwood said to me a couple
years ago I was asking him about just
stuff we were sitting on the set while
they were setting up a shot and and he
said you know people of people talk
about my movies you know they say well
this one's a masterpiece or that one's
no good and he goes I love all of them
you go and I know exactly why I made
each one of them and I wouldn't do
anything differently if I had to do it
again
Al Pacino said the secret to success
what does he know yeah exactly
well yeah well I was gonna say he said
the secret to success is learning his
lines old learning your lines what do
you reckon the sacred to success I never
heard him I never heard that that's
great that is definitely one of the the
secrets to success yeah having something
to say and knowing what it is yeah
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mr. playthroughs
101 asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are made of
profound eggs leave in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I also
love to know which of the top ten rules
here had the biggest impact on you and
why what change you're gonna make what
realization did you come to after
watching this video leave in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally one thing give a
quick shout-out to Xavier from sent lion
calm thank you so much you're by my book
it really means a lot to me those you
watching you want a chance at a shout
out in a future video make sure to pick
up a copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon
[Music]
oh hello oh hi fine
so do you ladies - do I come you I am
here a bit I'm here you know from time
to time do you go to school there yeah
so I think I had a class with you I am
okay mister maybe yes that's what it was
if you don't necessarily I'd not
remember me you know I like it here it
doesn't mean because I go here about my
genius I am a very snide hey how's it
going how are you doing why I don't know
what class did you did you say that was
this just history
it must have been a survey course I know
yeah was surveys Russian check it out
she got costs with big good class how'd
you like that course you know frankly I
found the class you know rather
elementary elementary you know I don't
doubt that it was yeah I I remember that
class it was on it was just between
recess and lunch
why don't you go away why don't you
relax don't worry just having fun with
my new friend that's all you could have
a problem no no no no no there's no
problem here I was hoping you might give
me some insight into the evolution of
the market economy in the southern
colonies my contention is that prior to
the Revolutionary War the economic
modalities especially in the southern
colonies could most aptly be
characterized as agrarian recap right of
course that's you hang on this you're a
first-year grad student you just got
finished reading some maxeen historian
Pete garrison probably gonna be
convinced to that till next month when
you get to James lemon and you're gonna
be talking about how the economies of
Virginia and Pennsylvania where
entrepreneurial and capitalist way back
in 1740 that's gonna last until next
year you're gonna be in here
regurgitating Gordon wood talking about
you know the pre-revolutionary utopia
and the capital forming Effects of
military mobilization as a matter of
fact I won't because would drastically
underestimates the impact which would
drastically underestimates the impact of
social distinctions predicated upon
wealth especially inherited wealthy you
got that from Vickers work in Essex
County page 98 right yeah I read that
too oh you're gonna play Gerace the
whole thing for us you have any thoughts
of your own on this matter but you just
set your thing you come into a buy you
read some obscure passage and then
pretend you pawn it off as your own as
your own idea just to impress some girls
embarrass my friend
see the sad thing about a guy like you
is in 50 is you're gonna start doing
some thinking on your owner you're gonna
come up with the fact that there are two
certainties in life one don't do that
and two you dropped 150 grand on a
[ __ ] education you could have got for
a dollar fifty and late Sacha's at the
public library yeah but I will have a
degree and you'll be serving my kids
fries at a drive-through on our way to a
skiing trip that may be yeah but at
least I won't be unoriginal but I mean
if you have a problem at that I mean we
could just step outside we could figure
it out oh man there's no problem it's
cool it's cool cool are you lady not
my boys await it's mine
[Music]
do you like apples
[Music]
yeah why got a number how do you like
their Maps
[Music]